you've heard the president in
drought-stricken California saying that
these weather emergencies in effect are
creating the conditions that government
has to act David I think that what it
brings to mine is how we utilize the
information that we have and we all know
and I think that bill would probably
agree with this neither he nor I are a
climate scientist he is an engineer and
actor I am a member of Congress and what
we have to do is look at the information
that we get from climate scientists as
you said so she she did something which
is very common in the climate denier
community or whatever you would call it
mr. Jha is to talk about credentials so
Marsha Blackburn representative in the
US Congress from Tennessee said why I'm
a congresswoman and Bill you're just a
mechanical engineer so you're not really
a climate scientist in it what I would
say is what we're talking about in this
level of climate science is you don't
need to be a full time climate scientist
to understand it
furthermore as far as my credentials
everybody I am my cankle engineer I took
a lot of physics all I did was take
physics physics physics physics and when
you're done with formal physics then you
take mechanical engineering which is
just applied physics okay I get it I can
understand what's going on we're putting
carbon dioxide in the air at a
prodigious rate and the world is getting
warmer and you can know this by looking
at the neutrons in the ice you can know
this by looking at the pollen grains per
cubic centimeter in the sediment of
ponds you can know this by looking
carefully at the rings on trees during
warm seasons wet seasons cold seasons
Rice's and you can work your way back
and figure out that the earth is getting
warmer faster than it's ever gotten
before and that's the problem it's not
that the world hasn't had more carbon
dioxides not the world hasn't been
warmer the problem is the speed at which
things are changing
we are inducing a sixth mass extinction
event kind of by accident and we don't
want to be the extinct T
if I'm a coin this noun so I mean as far
as miss Blackburn sounded like she'd
been coached on it denial
bullet points or talking points and I
very much enjoy taking those people on
but meemaw it breaks my heart because we
got work to do and the fossil fuel
industry has really gotten in their ears
and it's really troublesome we're the
world's most technically advanced
country or for the US isn't the most
technically advanced it certainly in the
top ten I mean you can say Japan New
Zealand are very sophisticated societies
but the u.s. is where iPhones are
invented what have you the Internet it's
still a significant place and so to have
a generation of science students being
brought up without awareness of climate
change is just a formula for disaster I
mean this is everybody kind of knows
this and so I think as an observer and I
may be wrong as I like to say you may be
right I as an observer it looks like the
US has strengths as its weakness so
people came here from all over the world
for freedom to think and act the way
they want the way they wanted especially
freedom of religion so we ended up with
both the people who framed the
Constitution which is fabulous thing and
people who asserted that that the Garden
of Eden was in Missouri and and there's
nobody there's no police for that sort
of thing you're allowed to believe
whatever you want it's great but with
that was this for them and I emphasize
them the other side consequence was that
of that was you could also ignore facts
of science for a while and now it's
coming to a head but man it's really
divisive isn't it's really something but
that living things change from
generation to generation through a
process that Darwin and Wallace Alfred
Wallace called natural selection or
descent with modification that's those
are true things that those are facts
tectonic plates move and that's a fact
and the world's getting warmer because
of human activity that's a fact if you
had somebody who really strongly
believed the earth was flat you wouldn't
have to have that person on a television
show with the people believe the earth
is round so the BBC is I understand just
got enough we got work to do we can't
it's not it's not one person versus the
other person it's 97 people versus three
people you just after a while you let's
move on there may have been there may
have been such debates at some time in
early human history but you wouldn't
have such a debate now